so the coronavirus
this is
a uh an image from the beginning of the
pandemic
uh so right at the beginning uh people
were focused on the 2019
novel coronavirus and they focused on
this epicenter in wuhan
where uh the comparison
was to previously existing viruses so
the middle east respiratory syndrome the
severe acute respiratory syndrome
and then they were looking at symptoms
and trying to understand
how is this novel virus different from
these other viruses that we already know
and we have studied because
coronaviruses have been studied
extensively for long periods of time
there are coronaviruses that infect
pigs and
cats and bats and all kinds of animals
they have had mild to severe outbreaks
like mers and sars but really they have
not spread that much and so what was new
and why was it important that we
understand the genomic
composition of this new virus
well the first thing that they did was
they did metagenomic sequencing
and metagenomic sequencing allows us to
take
all of the genomic material in a sample
and then try to understand
what is the actual full sequence of a
particular element so meta means a
collection or a combination of many
different examples and here we're trying
to understand what these examples
actually tell us about that one
consensus genome that we can call the
assembled genome the full genome of this
particular virus
and when they did that they
then started looking at uh how do we
take this denovo assembled genome and
start comparing it to existing genomes
so how does source 2 or this novel
coronavirus compare to the existing in
coronavirus that we already know and we
understand and then we can go into
biological interpretation thinking about
how can it be different how can it
function differently how can it cause an
infection in a different way
so one of the critical things to
understand about this is that this
particular type of data that they were
using high throughput or next generation
sequencing data is actually a series of
very short reads arranging anywhere
between 150 and 300 base pairs in length
and they had to align into some other
reference
to understand the differences so what
kinds of differences could there be
so here we have the reference here we
have what's called coverage or all of
the reads that we have
and then we can start looking for
variation so one type of a variation is
a substitution right so we identify here
1213 that's the position on the genome
and we have five reads that all agree
that this is different from what we have
in the original sequence
and that's called a substitution
another type of a substitution as you
can see right here
is a substitution where we only have two
reads
right and they don't agree they don't
agree with the reference but they don't
also agree with each other
and finally another example that we have
here is an insertion which we can say
it's an insertion in the genome or a
deletion in the reads that we have
but ultimately this is a deletion
that we need to identify
as a
kind of something that we trust evidence
that we trust or something questionable
and so a few
conclusions arise from this brief
example one of the conclusions is that
the data can be more complex than it is
presented
the other one
is that
some of the regions are going to be more
trusted and others are going to be less
trusted
and we need to understand how the data
looks but also what the analysis was
that we used to be able to give this a
biological interpretation
so because of these elements we need to
start looking deeper at the data and not
only trusting whatever is being
published but really asking questions
and we ask questions of data using
analytical methods
so let's take an example of from this
pandemic and briefly go through
how to do that
so very early on
there was a paper that was published
because everybody was concerned you know
where is this pandemic coming from was
it engineered on purpose you know what's
really going on and so a lot of people
were asking these questions and there
was a paper that was called the proximal
origins of source code 2
and i'll share the link here in the chat
where there were several arguments
presented about the potential reasoning
of how
people who
specialize in research in bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
think about
this data that emerged from this
outbreak
and so this is what they told us
they told us that
we have
the nucleotide sequence
we have the amino acid sequence we
understand what proteins are being
produced from this amino acid sequence
and therefore if we can identify the
relationship between multiple selected
strains of this virus that we have fully
sequenced
we can try to understand
why
this virus
occurred as a natural outbreak
and where could it potentially have come
from what was the potential intermediate
and the original source of this pandemic
so how did they do this
the first example that i want to tell
you show you is an example using the
t-bone for platform and this will be a
way for us to kind of explore the
platform but also continue talking about
this subject so the deep info platform
is something that
you have access to through your account
and in on this platform we will look at
uh an alignment so how do we analyze and
align these uh sequences to the
reference genome and what's called
phylogenetic tree construction so we're
gonna try and do some of these examples
but just so that you know you will have
access to this platform for the duration
of this program
and you will have five terabytes of
storage which will have a large number
of capabilities and you will have our
technical support to help you get
through some of these initial stages
so on the platform there are two
specific sections that we want to focus
on first
one is alignment to a reference right so
there we align reads to the reference
genome and we can identify specific
variants
or
alignment multiple sequence alignment
where we have multiple sequences that we
want to compare to each other and that
allows us to study relationships between
them by looking at a phylogenetic tree
the first pipeline organizes these these
methods right so each button here
represents a method
and as you can see those methods will be
con
constructed into a pipeline so series of
methods organized sequentially one after
the other
given some input make intermediate
outputs and then eventually produce a
resolved what we call a result and we'll
see that that could be the alignment
file or that could be a phylogenetic
tree so this pipeline will look like
this we'll take
the faster files of the spike protein
and then we will load them into this
pipeline
we will just use one button called
multiple sequence alignment
then we'll look at multiple sequence
visualization
and end
and as a result we will have this
interactive visualization that will
allow us to
navigate those sequences okay so we will
do this in the program we will not spend
too much time on this now to practically
go through this but then also after that
i will show you a pipeline that produces
a phylogenetic tree
so let me briefly show i'm sure that
most of you are already familiar with
these methods which is great but just as
a reminder refresher i will show you how
this might work
okay so first of all thank you just3 for
sharing the link if everyone can go to
the
server and let me know once you're in
by putting in yes or
one
into
the chat box
uh if you're having trouble logging in
right now we can figure out what the
issue might be
so all of you should have the login
information if you don't we'll be able
to email that to you so let's just go
ahead and try that right now
okay so please let me know if you're
having trouble logging in other than
that if you are in and you can see what
i see and you can go right here and see
your email address
all right great thank you katie katie is
logged in anyone else
okay
so clement uh maybe you can try later
okay uh and let us know okay ecta is not
able to
uh
so maybe
ecta could you please share the email
address that you are trying to log in
with
uh so narika are you in here
yes india i have taken this email
address and i'll help you with that
perfect
all right great so
once you're logged in
uh for those of you that were able to
what you want to do is you want to go
right here into phylogenetic analysis
and i'll just show you briefly how this
works so you can either go into this
section and that will allow you to
upload files and actually do the
analysis
or you can click on this
drop down and you will see some demo
pipelines
and so in the demo pipelines
you will see right here source code to
origin
which is a pipeline that already has
been finished and you can simply click
on each button
see what the button does and then
prepare a very simple pipeline so what
we'll do is start multiple sequence
alignment
convert that multiple sequence alignment
to amino acids
this is a way to look at specific
positions in terms of mutation rate that
helps us make more precise estimates of
time
based on mutation rate
then we will combine all kinds of
phylogeny methods together to prepare a
phylogenetic tree
we will analyze all of these
phylogenetic trees and select the
average one between multiple methods
which is a method in bioinformatics that
often is used when you have many
different things to do the same
step
and then we will run the pipeline
okay
so again start
multiple sequences alignment multiple
sequence alignment a a amino acid
select codon position msa all phytology
method tree space end let me know when
you have it
okay did anyone
did anyone complete a pipeline like this
if you have then you should go to click
pipeline output files and find that you
can download here a variety of files
from this download folder
okay i'll just give it a minute
later on you'll be able to go back and
now we'll actually show you where to
find this analysis in greater detail and
understand it but this is just to
introduce you to the tool today right so
this is just a way
to prepare a number of files that you
could either visually see like a pdf
download as a faster file
or potentially additional files like
this full table tsv
and the free pre-file we'll talk about
those in future sessions
has anyone been able to run this demo
pipeline or is anyone struggling to find
where exactly i found it
okay
so um
again let's go into areas of analysis
how do you log in so i can log out real
quick
you see if i log out you click on the
login button right here
and you can use here your email address
with whatever password you have to
access the omix logic portal
so if you have created your account
okay you gotta be logged in so let me
log in
so here i'm logged in
and now you click not on this not on
file generic analysis but you click down
on this button and you go to source code
to origin
okay
so isha were you able to click there
oh yes so up till now i can but when i
come to 5003 i wasn't able to click it
it wasn't showing
so you don't see this demo
uh so
all this i can see but when i come to
the pipeline in the last step i can't
click that one yeah
you can't click on this one
yeah
okay well let's try that together so
here i click on start
multiple sequence alignment
multiple multiple sequence alignment a a
select codon position and then this
should be highlighted like this
okay
tree space
okay
and
okay thank you
all right
excellent okay very simple
uh pipeline
again take a look at these output files
we're not going to go through them in
detail the objective of today's session
is just to introduce you to some of
these tools
but if you have completed what we just
did then you know that you can always go
back
and you will find under all of these
different pipelines some examples that
you can go through and those examples
will be used throughout the different
sections that we will do right so take a
look at them
now one of the pipelines that i made
to kind of introduce some of the tools
has an additional button for
visualization right because just having
a faster file is not very useful and i
have this visualization and in this
visualization i have a number of spike
protein sequences aligned to each other
okay so
why are we looking at these sequences
aligned to each other the reason we are
looking at them is because they can
reveal
a very specific
pattern
that the authors of this paper in nature
in nature medicine
kind of linked used to
link this novel coronavirus in humans
to a proximal origin to where potential
could have come from
how did they do it
so first of all
they selected very specific sequences
they said let's take human source code
to this new corona virus and let's take
the bat
rad g13 a
genome that was sequenced very recently
before this novel coronavirus emerged a
pangolin starscoff ii
sequence and then some previous uh
sequences of stars cove one
from human and from back and so the
first thing that they found is that
the closest ones are human bat and
pangolin right
and here they noticed some very specific
similarities that were present in some
but not all
and since the pangolin bats and human
source growth ii overall were more
closely related to each other then they
said well in specific positions
pangolin actually resembles some
important features for its ability to
infect humans
more than the rad g13 bad genome right
and so that was their first conclusion
they said the receptor binding domain
we'll talk about that in a second is
much more closely resembled in the
pangolin sequence to the human rather
than the bad g third ratchet or t
and the second thing that they found was
that even though that they found these
important similarities in the receptor
binding domain
in the polybasic cleavage site which is
another important section of that spike
protein
they found this unique sequence that was
only present in the human source code 2
which is
p-r-r-a-r sequence that was different
from all the rest
now to get to these conclusions quickly
we need to master some tools and these
tools oftentimes include some of the
simple things that we just did like
putting together buttons or sometimes we
need to go more in depth
and let's take a look at how you can
practice those things as a part of this
program as well